My Harvard education, well, it went on
for a while. So it is one part
inspiration and nine parts perspiration
whereas with the poets it's the
other way around and that's why people
find them so annoying, they say I'm
not looking out the window I'm working
working visually working with
people and you know capturing something
extraordinary about ordinary life
If I could encourage young girls to pick up
the guitar and maybe be part of that
movement that would allow that sexism
in my end of the world to be eradicated
a little bit that I could do something
good with this guitar. I took a class
with a guy named Anthony Kubiak and I
had taken a few of his classes he was a
wonderful teacher and I started Good
Will Hunting and it was a playwriting class
I never took film seriously I, you know, I
came much more from theatre before
Put yourself in situations where you can
play with the best musicians possible
and play with honesty and integrity
Oh well it was it was great because I could
get into the Widener Library stacks
which is where I put the secret service
in the Republic of Gilead
I think the time it's never been better
for music if you're good you're going to
get through no matter what
Through music, it's a medium you could
actually explore everything and then I
was able to to say okay I do have a
passion this is something I can readily
sign on to do.